prácticamente desde georgetown y bruce
que empezó esta guerra todos los
presidentes han querido retirar las
tropas de hecho llama mucho la atención
un comentario del ex presidente de
donald trump que dijo que está retirada
de tropas sería muy diferente o su
gobierno si él fuese todavía presidente
dijo que se haría bajo
condiciones diferentes y que sería muy
exitosa y muy buena la retirada de sus
tropas sin embargo pues bailén el show
les ha reiterado ya en varias ocasiones
que está convencido y no se arrepiente
de su decisión de retirar las tropas
decisión que ni siquiera obama pudo
cumplir a pesar de que fue una promesa
de campaña en cuanto a las tropas y en
cuanto a cómo están preparados los
arcanos pues son cerca de 300.000
hombres afganos entrenados por los
estadounidenses que están en la que
están tratando de hacer contrapeso a los
talibanes que son 75.000 hombres así que
muchos analistas dicen que están
suficientemente preparados lo que pasa
es que hay mucha división en afganistán
y eso está afectando entonces pues la
avanzada de forma positiva para los
talibanes en